this is their games
karate making its debut japan
hosting the world but rather than
celebrating the back of the pandemic
tokyo is still fighting it
and it's already snatched away their
chance to take part
i'm so sad
welcome to japan home to the world's
biggest experiment
in the time of a pandemic there's
pre-departure tests
tracking apps paperwork saliva tests
it's a good safety net but it can never
be perfect
and the japanese know it their recovery
games
are being held under a state of covet
emergency
the olympics should be a symbol of unity
and peace and you know the prime
minister said it's a simple victory
over the coming pandemic but
unfortunately
it's becoming totally opposite
team gb are games ready but the athletes
aren't going it alone
no family no friends here watching the
moments
that could define their lives they were
going to come out so not having them
here is kind of a bit disappointing but
at the same time i think it's the right
call
i know that they're all going to be at
home watching me as it stands
375 athletes will be in the team gb
bubble and they have to maintain it as
we know
you know quick outbreaks of the covert
variant it can bring
teams down they can bring delegations
down quite quickly but we're not in that
position the hard reality
is that nobody can guarantee how these
games will pan out
there are always problems there are
always worries before any olympic games
but this does
genuinely feel different we know that
the olympic spirit can achieve
extraordinary things
but can it overcome covet japan has been
racing to improve its slow vaccination
rate
just 20 percent of people are protected
finnish
they can't afford a super spreading
event but many fear
one is just beginning the games are
on as one olympic official has said
only armageddon will stop it now
tom palman's here sky news tokyo